où
[Musique]
depuis je venais souvent chemin est ce
que vous voyez ce n'est pas correct
parce que je faisais ce n'est pas
correct que je suis négatif
allez jouer et perçoit ceni les gens
allaient jouer tout seul dans mon jardin
et l'eau en arrière c'est négligent ces
jeunes parents se sont mariés à 18 ans
ils ont rapidement un premier bébé à ce
moment là ils vivent en ville loin de
leurs familles et de leurs racines
attikameks mon super she came la voisine
bas ou ap papandreou celle d'à côté
signalement leur dossier s'aggrave quand
tu as des pays jugent que le bébé à un
retard de langage on les accuse de
négligence mais on saura plus tard qu'il
a eu trouble du spectre de l'autisme
sévère tout à coup il disait votre
enfant
parce qu'il venait juste de borena dans
ce tableau dames et et comprenez mon
enfant mais pas le palais pas encore et
jetés chaque école et avait dit ça le
couple a quatre enfants en moins de six
ans deux ont des besoins particuliers
les parents sont dépassés
la dpj retire les deux aînés de la
famille chaque fois qu'ils venaient à
l'improviste
vous sentez toujours aux biens
l'intérieur de moi me sens intimidée
je me sentais rabais simon desbiens nous
on était toujours tout petit mais quel
os ont toujours préféré les enfants sont
d'abord envoyé chez leurs grands parents
après un an la dpj décide de les placer
plutôt dans une famille de blancs qui a
plus d'expérience avec les autistes
seuls les grands parents ont le droit de
les voir une fois par mois pendant
quelques heures une opa du boucau à
cause d'eux autres sur
notre lié d'affection beaucoup si ça
faisait mal des fois parce que six mois
qui a mené aux enfants à leurs amis
d'agde et puis c'était comme ça à chaque
mois c'était comme
c'est pas à les abandonner pendant cette
période le papa commence à boire après
six journées travaille beaucoup de
pression j'avais ma job j'avais ma
petite famille avec toutes les demandes
de la dpj un moment donné j'étais
violent a beaucoup aggravé l'eau le dos
il ya eu le la dpj a eu raison dans
certains points la coordonne au père de
suivre une thérapie mais il ne réussit
pas à sortir du cycle infernal jusqu'à
ce que les dpj transfère le dossier au
nouveau système d'intervention
d'autorité attikameks on va pouvoir
explose enfin on va pouvoir préserver
leur identité leur intégrité en 2018 les
attikameks sont les premiers autochtones
au québec à obtenir le droit de gérer la
protection de l'enfance sur leur
territoire leur but garder les enfants
dans la communauté autant que possible
on veut pas derrière ce n'est parce que
je sais que dans le passé il ya eu des
enfants qui ont été placés à l'extérieur
on les a pas revus nicole black
accompagne depuis 23 ans des enfants en
tyka mec qui vivent des situations
difficiles
elle a travaillé avec la dpj plus au
sein du système d'intervention
d'autorité attikameks le siao ce que
j'ai vu moi dans ma pratique c'est que
la dpg quand kaka car c'est comme ces
débarque avec ses grands talents
tandis qu'à l'est c'est assez
dire on s'en va
tranquillement on impose bout en bout ce
qu'il faut non plus
cet autre couple a maintenant la garde
légale de quatre de leurs petits enfants
les deux plus vieux ont d'abord vécu
cinq ans dans une famille d'accueil il
ne parle plus attikameks et peine à
communiquer avec leurs frères et soeurs
précise qu est ce que c
est toi qu'est ce que tu as ainsi
l'autorité attikameks cherche à
préserver l'identité et la culture des
enfants qui sont sous leur protection
les valeurs traditionnelles comme un
saint à nos enfants ce qu'est l'île
depuis vie parlait pas mais qui
comprenait pas que là il commence à
parler et qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
les parents pour qu'on vous demande de
vous occuper de vos petits enfants une
femme avaient été
visités sont des promeneurs qui est
rendu à l'air d'en laisser la latitude
mange avec marie avec des mains de
brûlures de cigarettes
mort à ce moment là les enfants sont
placés par la dpj dans une famille
d'accueil quand l'autorité attikameks
prend aussi en charge quelques années
plus tard on organise un conseil de
famille cette étape est au coeur de la
démarche autochtone
quand on retire un enfant de son milieu
on pense tout le temps en premier vers
la famille élargie la mode la mode comme
attentes les grands parents comment ça
se passe les gens se fassent pleure ses
oreilles ou et la colère on le saura il
ya des émotions après ça ça devient
en harmonie et les rires et une solution
est trouvée s'en est trouvée si on ne
s'entend pas au sein de la famille
élargie la discussion se poursuit avec
le conseil des sages ici un parent
continue de s'opposer à une mesure le
dossier est référé au tribunal avec la
proche attikameks la judiciarisation des
dossiers a chuté de 80%
ce premier couple dont on vous a parlé
au début a eu l'impression pendant cinq
ans cadets piger cherchait toujours à
les prendre en photo selon une autorité
attikameks les aident davantage avec une
approche ancrés dans leurs cultures
toutes sortes de thérapies mongin
s'était basé sur des bases et sur la
tradition là j'ai beaucoup appris
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup appris à
la guérison
culturelles et traditionnelles
c'est d'être un présent de la forêt là
s'est allumée ressources il lèche
shimizu qui allait me temime il ya des
violets
le père qui n'avait jamais été violent
avant l'intervention de la dpj a appris
à gérer sa colère ce qui a permis de
réunir la famille
[Musique]
les quatre enfants vivent maintenant
avec leurs parents avec le soutien
continu du système d'intervention
attikameks